ان يعني اشاد الفريق ضاحي خلفان تميم نائب
رئيس الشرطه والامن العام بدبي بدوله
الامارات العربيه المتحده بمرشح الرئاسه
المصريه المشير عبد الفتاح السيسي معددا
الصفات الانسب في شخصيته ان
رجل يحترم
ويقدر ورمز من رموز الاستقلاليه
الوطنيه
اثنين عمر 60 عام فهو قادر على العمل
الميداني ثلاثه له روابط استراتيجيه مع
كبريات الدول الخليجيه القادر على
الاستثمار في
مصر اربعه رجل يعني متدين ولكن لا يرتبط
يعني تطرف ديني
مستقل يعني هو مسلم وسطي
خمسه يعني طلب من الشعب ان يفوضه وخرج 30
مليون
20 مليون قولوا بت تقولون ملايين ملات
الشوارع استجابه لكلمه حينما قال فوضوني
لحل الاشكاليه بمصر فكانت هذه على الاقل
مؤشر على ان في الشعب عنده ثقه في في
السيسي خامسا لو لو نظرنا وقرانا لغه
الجسد
عنده نجد ان يعني هادي
طبع
مفكر قادر على ارسال رساله هادئه الى
المتلقي وان عنده ثقه في النفس سادسا هو
رجل
استخبارات ولهذا بيكون قادر على اكتشاف كل
الايادي القدر اللي قد
يعني تسعى من اجل اخلال بامن مصر القومي
فهو رجل يعني يستطيع على الاقل يكتشف
الاعيب
الخصوم ومصر في هذا الوقت
يعني ثامنا هي بحاجه الى رجل في هذه
المسائل وتوقع في مقابله خاصه بموقع سي ان
ان بالعربيه فوز المشير السيسي
بالانتخابات المصريه التي ستجري الشهر
القادم ما لم يكن هناك تدخلا يعتمد يعني
يعتمد اذا دخل مثلا اذا دخل في
يعني الانتخابات يعني ايادي
خفيه يعني دوليه لها قدره على انها مثلا
تتبع المنافع والمصالح
والرشاوى للناس قد تتغير النتيجه يجوز لكن
لو كان هذا ما في السيسي بيوس الفريق
خلفان الذي اكد اثناء اللقاء غير مره انه
يتحدث عن مشاعره كمواطن اماراتي متابع
تمنى ان لا يتم التدخل بالشان المصري من
الخارج اتمنى على الدول التي لها نوايا لا
قدر الله شريره في ان تعبث بامن مصر ان
تتوقف عند حتى لان هذا قد يقلب
المنطقه على مصالحها في المنطقه كلها يعني
انا اتمنى ان ان مخابرات القرب لا تسعى
جاهده الى مثلا خلق يعني شيء من
الاضطرابات في مصر لان سوف تكون الرده
عنيفه بعد ذلك وستكون المنطقه يعني مشتعله
وسيكون يعني علاقه القرب والوطن العربي
علاقه فيها كثير من التحديات التي لا تخدم
الصالح ايش الصالح العام ولهذا اتمنى ان
من يسمع كلامي الان ان يعلم تماما بان
محاوله تفتيت مصر ستكون جريمه لا تخفر وان
العالم العربي كله بيهب مساعده ودعم ووقوف
لمصر ولو ادى احنا كمواطنين يعني مستقلين
في هذه الامه ان ان نكون داخل مصر نقب من
اجل ثبات ووقوفها
كدوله نفذيها بارواحنا واذا شعرنا بان
هناك سعي من دول قربيه لا قدر الله يعني
انا ح يعني هذا سينامي طيب ما في افتراء
افتراء لو ان في مثل هذه النوايا فمعناته
ان يعني القرب سو سوف يواجه لاول مره في
حياته مارد عربي قومي يسعى الى ان يعني
يكون خصم لدود ل وعما اذا كان يعتقد كرجل
امن ان ما يجري في مصر حاليا هو نتيجه
انضمام اطراف خارجيه قال الفريق خلفان انه
تنبا بذلك مسبقا تبين انا قبل ان ان تظهر
بوادر وجود جماعات في سيناء في مقابله
تلفزيونيه حذرت بان يمكن الجماعات
الاسلاميه تلتقي في سيناء لما قالوا لي
سينا لماذا لان يمكن يجون من سوريا ومن
دول خليجيه ومن اليمن ومن ربما يعني اماكن
مختلفه ومن ليبيا ويحلون ايش ويحلون في
سيناء وع عقب اربع خمس شهور من تصري صريح
هذا حدث ان جماعه فعلا صار ان في جماعات
موجوده لكن جيش مصر يعني قوي مره اخرى
اتمنى ان
القرب يبتعد عن هذه المنطقه المحظوره
واقول محظوره لان حقيقه يعني بان يعني اذا
اذا اذا سعت لا قدر الله هذه الجهات الى
خلخله الوضع الامني في مصر فستكون
يعني طامه كبرى كارولين فرج لسي ان ان
بالعربيه
دبي